l'homme absurde et celui qui ne se
sépare pas du temps écrit Camus il
voulait dire par là que le temps n'était
pas condamné à être notre ennemi et que
le meilleur moyen de le combattre
c'était de l'épouser à chaque fois que
vous épousez le temps vous vous
réconcilier avec l'absurde à chaque fois
que vous créez au point d'oublier le
temps vous enlacez l'absurde
Sisyphe d'abord désespéré de son sort
modifia un jour la perception qu'il
avait de sa condition il se vit comme
une force de réalisation il se trouva
une raison d'exister
incarnez la révolte c'est incarner la
flamme aucune absurdité ne saurait
éteindre à chaque fois que vous incarnez
la révolte à chaque fois que vous
perforez l'absurde par votre
redressement par votre affirmation par
votre puissance d'accomplissement vous
existez